what is feeling crushed mean and feel
like in poker is it like that you just
can't read at all you've been constantly
pressured you feel off balance you try
to Bluff and the person reads you
perfectly that kind of stuff it's it's a
this is a really really excellent
question because I think this has
parallels to a bunch of other things
okay let's just use poker as a microcosm
to explain a bunch of other systems or
games
maybe it's um
running a company
or investing okay so let's use those
three examples but we use poker to
explain it what does success look like
well success looks like you have
positive expected value
right in poker the simple way to
summarize that is
your opponent
let's just say you and I are playing are
going to make a bunch of mistakes
there's a bunch of it that's going to be
absolutely perfect
and then there's a few spots where you
make mistakes
and then there's a bunch of places in
the poker game where I play perfectly
and I make a few mistakes
basically your mistakes minus my
mistakes is The Edge right
that's that's period That's How poker
works if I make fewer mistakes than you
make I will make money and I will win
that is the objective of the game
translate that into business
you're running a company
you have a team of employees you have a
pool of human capital that's capable of
being productive in the world and
creating something
but you are going to make mistakes
in making that
maybe it doesn't completely fit the
market maybe it's mispriced maybe it
actually doesn't require all of the
people that you need so the margins are
wrong
and then there's the competitive set of
all the other Alternatives that customer
has
their mistakes minus your mistakes
is the expected value of Google Facebook
Apple
Etc
okay now take investing
every time you buy something somebody
else on the other side is selling it to
you
is that their mistake we don't know yet
but their mistakes minus your mistakes
is how you make a lot of money over long
periods of time as an investor
somebody sold you Google at forty
dollars a share you bought it and you
kept it
huge mistake on their part minimum
mistakes on your part
the difference of that is the money that
you made
so life can be summarized in many ways
in that way so the question is
what can you do about other people's
mistakes and the answer is nothing
that is somebody else's game you can try
to influence them you could try to
subvert them maybe you plant a spy
inside of that other person's company to
sabotage them I guess there are things
at the edges that you can do
but my firm belief is that life success
really boils down to how do you control
your mistakes
now this is a bit counterintuitive
the way you control your mistakes is by
making a lot of mistakes
so taking risks you have to is somehow
you have to you to minimize the number
of mistakes let's just say you want to
find love yeah you know you want to find
something go on deeply connected with
yeah
are you do you do that by not going out
on dates and yes
sorry sorry you're the only person that
thinks that's yesterday no I'm joking
I'm joking no but you know what I mean
like you have to date people you have to
open yourself up you have to be
authentic and like you put you you give
yourself a chance to get hurt yes but
you're a good person so you know what
happens when you get hurt that is
actually their mistake
okay and if you are inauthentic that's
your mistake
that's a controllable thing in you you
can tell them the truth who you are and
say Here's my pluses and minuses my
point is there are very few things in
life
that you can't break down I think into
that very simple idea
and in terms of your mistakes Society
tells you don't make them because we
will judge you and we will look down on
you
and I think the really successful people
realize that actually no
it's the cycle time of mistakes that
gets you to success
because your error rate will diminish
the more mistakes that you make You
observe them you figure out where it's
coming from is it a psychological thing
is it a you know cognitive thing and
then you fix it so the implied thing
there is that there's a
uh in in business and investing in poker
and dating in life is that there's this
platonic GTO Game Theory optimal thing
out there and so when you say mistakes
you're always comparing to that optimal
path you could have taken I think uh
slightly different I would say mistake
is maybe a bad proxy but it's the best
proxy I have for learning
but I'm using the language of what
Society tells you sure got it Society
tells you that when you try something
and it doesn't work it's a mistake
so I just use that word because it's the
word that resonates most with most
people got it the real thing that it is
is learning yeah it's like in neural
networks it's lost it's a neural network
it's lost exactly uh yeah right so
you're using the mistake that is most uh
the the word that is most understandable
especially by the way people experience
it I guess most of life is a sequence of
mistakes the problem is when you use the
word mistake and you think about
mistakes it actually has the
counterproductive effect of you becoming
conservative in is just being
risk-averse
so that if you folk if you re if you
flip it and say try to maximize the
number of successes somehow that leads
you to take more risk
um mistake scares people
I think mistakes scare people because
Society likes
these very simplified boundaries of who
is winning and who is losing
and they want to reward
people who make traditional choices
and succeed
but the thing is what's so
corrosive about that
is that they're actually not even being
put in a position to actually make a
quote-unquote mistake and fail so I'll
give you if you look at like getting
into an elite school
right Society rewards you for being in
the Ivy Leagues
in a way that you know in my opinion
incorrectly doesn't reward you for being
in a non-ivy league School
there's a certain level of status and
presumption of intellect and capability
that comes with being there
but that system doesn't really have a
counterfactual because it's not as if
you both go to MIT and Ohio State
and then we can see two versions of Lex
Friedman so that we can figure out that
The Jig Is up and there was no
difference
right and so instead it reinforces this
idea that there is no truth-seeking
function there is no way to actually
make this thing whole
and so it tells you you have to get in
here and if you don't your life is over
you've made a huge mistake you know or
you've failed completely
and so you have to find different unique
ways of dismantling this this is why you
know part of what I realized
where I got very lucky is
I had no friends in high school
I had a few cohort of acquaintances
but part of being so hyper provisional
when I grew up was I was so ashamed of
that world that I had to live in I
didn't want to bring anyone into it I
could not see myself that anybody would
accept me
but the thing with that is that I had no
definition of what expectations should
be so they were not Guided by the people
around me and so I would escape to
Define my expectations it's interesting
but you didn't feel
um like your dad
didn't put you in a prison of
expectation
or we because like that's if you know a
friend like that so the flip side of
that you don't have any other signals
it's very easy to believe like when
you're in a cult that well he you know
he was angry he pushed me
he used me as a mechanism to alleviate
his own frustration and this may sound
very crazy but he also believed in me
and so that's what created this weird
Duality where you were just I was always
confused you could be somebody great he
believed that you could be he did him
because I couldn't reconcile then the
other half of the day you know those
behaviors
but what it allowed me to do was I
escaped in my mind
and I found these archetypes around me
that were saviors to me
so you know I grew up in Ottawa Ontario
Canada I grew up right at the point
where the Telecom boom was happening
companies like Nortel and Newbridge
networks and mitel Bell Northern
research these were all built in in the
suburbs of Ottawa
and so there were these Larger than Life
figures entrepreneurs Terry Matthews
Michael Copeland
and so I thought I'm going to be like
them I would read Forbes Magazine I
would read Fortune Magazine I would look
at the rich people on that list and say
I would be like them
not knowing
that maybe that's not who you wanted it
to be
but it was a lifeline and it kept my
mind relatively whole
because I could direct my ambition in a
Direction
and so why that's so important just
circling back to this is I didn't have a
group of friends who were like I'm going
to go to Community College
you know I didn't have a group of
friends that said well you know the goal
is just to go to university get a simple
job and like you know join the public
service have a good life
and so because I had no expectations and
I was so afraid to venture out of my own
house I never saw what middle class life
was like and so I never aspired to it
now if I was close to it I probably
would have aspired to it because I my
parents in their best year made 32 000
Canadian together
and if you're trying to raise a family
of five people on thirty two thousand
dollars it's a complicated job and most
of the time they were probably making 20
something thousand and I was working
since I was 14. so I knew that our
station in life was not the destination
we had to get out
um but because I didn't have an obvious
place it's not like I had a best friend
whose house I was going to and I saw
some normal functional home
if I had had that
in this weird way I would have aspired
to that